[Music]
thank you were just greeted by people in
Schaumburg Illinois where I've been
visiting now I'm driving home and I'm
filming Brotherhood 2.0 while driving is
that safe no it's not safe but if I
don't film Brotherhood 2.0 while driving
when will i film it I'm gonna get home
right before midnight observation people
in passing cars look at you funny when
you're driving down the road holding a
camera in front of your face anyway Hank
I have to publicly state that I do not
recommend video blogging while driving
at 72 miles an hour unless you are nine
months into a 12-month project and have
not yet missed a day in that project
okay Hank I just pulled on merging
traffic Hank I just passed an outlet
mall and I was like who goes to outlet
malls anyway and there was a billboard
that said Matt the outlet mall come see
the beef jerky outlet and I was like oh
my god must get over must get in the
right lane must exit now but then there
was this tragically long line of semi
trucks and I wasn't able to exit so I
miss the beef jerky outlet I mean Hank
think of the beef jerky deals we should
have more awesome outlets like that
maybe we can go to winter South Dakota
and build like a nerdfighter outlet mall
we could have like a put stuff on your
head outlet that would sell like 85,000
different items that will fit on top of
your head at wholesale prices of course
we got to have a peeps outlet they'd
sell like every possible color peeps
stamped into every shape and size in the
world by the way Hank my lifelong dream
a peep in the shape of me and of course
there would have to be a pants outlet
and as I envisioned it Hank all the
pants we sell in our pants outlet would
be emblazoned with pineapples the
pineapple would tell you that you've got
a pair of real legitimate 100%
nerdfighter pants why a pineapple Hank
because it's the international sign for
welcome it's like saying welcome to my
pants and speaking of welcoming people
to my pants Hank I'd like to thank you
for getting the brother to 2.04 my pants
back Oh Hank I think I'm gonna go back
to driving now so that's it for me in
Indiana where the road is flat the day
is long and the
corn is plentiful I'll see you tomorrow
PS Hank it occurs to me that we've gone
nine months in this video blog and we've
never really disagreed so I've been
thinking that maybe it's time for just a
little tiny feud I don't even know what
we could disagree about but maybe if we
can come up with something then the
nerdfighters can pick who wins all I
know is this Hank if we do have a feud
like a pirate at a ninja convention
you're gonna get pwned PPS tomorrow's
the yetis birthday yay Sarah oh and Hank
PPP s like it says on my friend Katie's
arm don't forget to be awesome